En la década de los 70, cuando la gente empezó a pensar otra vez,
dijeron, "Sí, bueno, por supuesto que hay trastornos del sueño en la esquizofrenia
porque toman antipsicóticos.
Son los antipsicóticos los que causan los problemas de sueño",
ignorando el hecho de que cien años antes,
la interrupción del sueño se había informado antes que los antipsicóticos.
¿Qué está pasando?
Muchos grupos están estudiando
condiciones como la depresión, la esquizofrenia y el trastorno bipolar
y lo que sucede en términos de la interrupción del sueño.
Tenemos un gran estudio que publicamos el año pasado sobre la esquizofrenia,
y los datos fueron extraordinarios.
En aquellos individuos con esquizofrenia,
gran parte del tiempo, estaban despiertos durante la fase de noche
y luego estaban dormidos durante el día.
Otros grupos no mostraron ningún tipo de patrones de 24 horas.
Su sueño estaba completamente destrozado.
algunos no tenían ninguna capacidad para regular su sueño por el ciclo luz-oscuridad.
Se levantaban más y más y más tarde.
y más tarde cada noche. Estaban destrozados.
¿Qué está pasando?
Y un descubrimiento realmente emocionante es que
el trastorno mental y el sueño no están simplemente asociados
sino que están vinculados físicamente dentro del cerebro.
Las redes neuronales que nos predisponen a un sueño normal,
que nos proveen un sueño normal,
y aquellas que nos dan salud mental normal, se superponen.
Y ¿cuál es la evidencia de esto?
Bueno, los genes que han demostrado ser muy importantes
en la generación de sueño normal,
cuando mutan, cuando cambian,
también predisponen a los individuos a problemas de salud mental.
Y el año pasado, publicamos un estudio
que demostró que un gen que se ha vinculado a la esquizofrenia,
cuando muta, también interrumpe el sueño.
Así que tenemos evidencia de una auténtica superposición mecánica
entre estos dos importantes sistemas.
Otro trabajo surgió de estos estudios.
El primero fue que la interrupción del sueño en realidad precede
ciertos tipos de enfermedades mentales,
y hemos demostrado que en esos individuos jóvenes
que corren un alto riesgo de desarrollar trastornos bipolares,
ya tienen una anormalidad del sueño
antes de cualquier diagnóstico clínico de trastorno bipolar.
La otra parte de los datos es que la interrupción del sueño
en realidad puede exacerbar,
empeorar el estado de los trastornos mentales.
Mi colega Dan Freeman, ha utilizado una gama de agentes
que han estabilizado el sueño y reducido los niveles de paranoia
en aquellos individuos, en un 50%.
Entonces, ¿Qué tenemos?
Tenemos, en estas conexiones, cosas realmente interesantes.
En términos de neurociencia, mediante la comprensión
de la neurociencia de estos dos sistemas,
estamos empezando a entender realmente cómo ambos, el dormir
y las enfermedades mentales, se generan y regulan dentro del cerebro.
La segunda área es que si podemos usar sueño
y los trastornos del sueño como una señal de advertencia temprana,
entonces tenemos la oportunidad de actuar.
Si sabemos que estos individuos son vulnerables,
la intervención temprana entonces se convierte en una posibilidad.
Y la tercera, que creo que es la más emocionante,
es que podemos pensar en los centros del sueño dentro del cerebro
como una nueva área terapéutica.
Estabilizando el sueño en aquellos individuos que son vulnerables,
ciertamente nos permite hacerlos más saludables,
pero también aliviar algunos de los terribles síntomas de los trastornos mentales.
Así que para finalizar.
Empecé diciendo que hay que tomar el sueño en serio.
Nuestras actitudes hacia el sueño son muy diferentes
desde una edad preindustrial,
cuando estábamos casi envueltos en un edredón.
Solíamos entender intuitivamente la importancia de dormir.
Y esto no es ninguna charlatanería.
Esto es una respuesta pragmática a la buena salud.
Si duermen bien, aumenta su concentración,
su atención, la toma de decisiones, la creatividad, las habilidades sociales, la salud.
Si duermen, se reducen los cambios de humor, el estrés,
los niveles de ira, la impulsividad,
y la tendencia a beber y tomar drogas.
Y terminamos diciendo
que la comprensión de la neurociencia del sueño
realmente está cambiando la manera de pensar acerca
de algunas de las causas de las enfermedades mentales,
y de hecho nos está proporcionando nuevas formas
para tratar estas afecciones increíblemente debilitantes.
Jim Butcher, el escritor de literatura fantástica, dijo,
"El sueño es Dios. Adórenlo".
Y sólo puedo recomendarles que hagan eso mismo.
Gracias por su atención.
(Aplausos)